pausa el vídeo y ve si puedes resolver
para x en esta ecuación averigua qué
valores de x satisfacen esta ecuación
que tengo aquí
ok vamos a resolverlo y la manera en la
que voy a resolverlo es aislando este x
+ 3 al cuadrado que tengo aquí de un
lado de la ecuación y la mejor manera
para hacer esto es sumar 4 de ambos
lados de la ecuación voy a sumar 4 aquí
y también voy a sumar 4 aquí de tal
manera que esté menos 4 con este 4 se
van a cancelar déjame cancelar los de
una vez y solamente me quedo con x + 3
al cuadrado déjame ponerlo así x + 3
esto elevado al cuadrado y del lado
derecho me voy a quedar solamente con
cuatro porque 0 + 4 es lo mismo que 4
así que lo voy a poner aquí esto va a
ser igual a 4 y ahora sí me puedo tomar
la raíz cuadrada de ambos lados porque
lo puedes pensar de esta manera si tengo
algo elevado al cuadrado igualado a 4
eso quiere decir que ese algo necesita
ser igual a más
2 entonces una manera de ver esto es
decir que x 3 déjame ponerlo así que x +
3 es igual a la raíz positiva y negativa
de 4 ahora ojalá que todo esto sea muy
intuitivo para ti si algo elevado al
cuadrado es igual a 4 si esto que tengo
aquí que está elevado al cuadrado es
igual a 4 eso quiere decir que entonces
este algo tiene que ser igual a la raíz
positiva de 4 o a la raíz negativa de 4
o bien será igual a 2 positivo o a 2
negativo por lo tanto lo podemos
escribir o x 3 es igual a 2 x + 3 es
igual a 2
x 3 x 3 es igual a menos 2 porque
observa si x 3 es igual a 2 2 al
cuadrado
es lo mismo que 4 y si x 3 es igual a
menos 2 menos dos al cuadrado también es
igual a 4 entonces cualquiera de estos
dos valores podría satisfacer nuestra
ecuación y si tenemos que x 3 es igual a
2 bueno y aquí podemos resolver para x
para eso voy a restar 3 de ambos lados
voy a restar 3 de ambos lados del lado
izquierdo estos dos se van y me voy a
quedar solamente con x y del lado
derecho me va a quedar 2 menos tres lo
cual es menos 1 x es igual a menos 1
y bueno ahora tengo esta ecuación de
aquí y voy a hacer lo mismo voy a quitar
3 de ambos lados de tal manera que del
lado izquierdo estos dos se van a ir y
solamente me voy a quedar con x mientras
que del lado derecho que me va a quedar
menos dos menos 3
es lo mismo que menos 5
entonces estas dos son las soluciones de
esta ecuación cuadrática con la que
empezamos y lo puedes verificar toma
estos valores de x y vamos a
sustituirlos aquí para que veas que en
efecto me da igual a cero si x es igual
a menos 1 entonces menos 13 es lo mismo
que 22 al cuadrados 4 menos 4 eso es lo
mismo que 0 y cuando x es igual a menos
5 menos 53 es menos 2 - 2 al cuadrado es
4 y 4 menos 4 es igual a cero entonces
estos dos son los valores posibles que
puede tomar x que satisfacen esta
ecuación ahora qué te parece si hacemos
otro ejercicio muy parecido pero que se
nos presenta de una manera distinta y
para eso déjame bajar la pantalla y dice
así
fd x es igual a x menos 2 al cuadrado
menos 9 y nos preguntan para qué valores
de x la gráfica ye igual a fx intersec a
al eje
así que por aquí déjame poner unos ejes
por aquí voy a poner a mi eje x más o
menos así y por aquí voy a poner a mi
eje ya que me va a quedar más o menos
así y vamos a poner que estos son
nuestros ejes este es mi eje y este es
mi eje x porque ahora me voy a tomar la
gráfica de una función que ojo la voy a
ver de manera general no forzosamente es
esta función
f x puede ser cualquier otra función
pero lo que quiero que te fijes es en lo
siguiente me voy a tomar por aquí la
gráfica de una función y voy a decir que
esta función de aquí no sé no
forzosamente es ésta fx es más le voy a
poner yo igual a gd x para que veas que
no forzosamente es esta función
fx pero lo importante y lo que quiero
que observes es lo siguiente que los
puntos de intersección con el eje x este
punto de aquí y este punto de aquí donde
tenemos intersección
con el eje x son los puntos donde vale
cero en este punto y vale cero y en este
punto también ya vale cero porque si te
das cuenta nuestra coordenada y en
cualquiera de estos dos puntos será
igual a cero eso significa que nuestra
función nuestra función es igual a cero
ahora bien esto significa que averiguar
los valores de x donde la gráfica
fx intersec a al eje x es exactamente lo
mismo es equivalente que decir para qué
valores de x f x es igual a 0
por lo tanto lo que queremos es saber
para qué valores aquí esta función es
igual a 0 y es más déjame escribirlo lo
que quiero es que x menos 2 al cuadrado
menos 9 sea igual a 0
y menos 2 al cuadrado menos 9 esto sea
igual a 0
y bueno resolver esto es muy parecido a
lo que hicimos acá arriba lo primero que
voy a hacer es sumar 9 de ambos lados y
voy a llegar a que x menos 2 al cuadrado
es igual a 9 y como vimos anteriormente
esto significa que x 2 debe de ser igual
a más menos la raíz cuadrada de 9 la
raíz cuadrada positiva o negativa de 9
entonces podemos decir que a x menos 2
es igual a 3
x 2 es igual a menos 3 ahora en esta
primera si sumas 2 de ambos lados
sumando 2 de ambos lados voy a obtener
que del lado izquierdo estos dos se van
y me queda que x es igual a 3 + 2 lo
cual es 5 y ahora esta otra si hago lo
mismo y sumó 2 de ambos lados sumo dos
de ambos lados voy a obtener bueno del
lado izquierdo me queda x igual a menos
tres más dos lo cual es menos 1 y bueno
inclusive lo puedes verificar si pones
el valor de 5 me va a quedar que 5 menos
2 lo cual es 3 si lo elevamos al
cuadrado eso me da 9 y si le quitamos 9
me da cero eso quiere decir que el punto
50 el punto 5 050 está en esta gráfica
que tengo aquí y de igual manera si
sustituye es el valor por menos uno me
quedaría menos 1 - 2
es menos tres y menos tres elevado al
cuadrado me va a dar nueve positivo
menos 9 será cero eso quiere decir que
también el punto menos 10 este también
estará en esta gráfica de aquí y justo
estos dos son los valores de x donde la
gráfica y igual a fx intersecta al eje x